[Music]
in the relatively new world of
free-to-play first-person shooters
Team Fortress 2 is relatively old
released in 2007 and set free in 2011
this class-based classic continues to
receive regular updates and attract a
robust player base well into its seventh
year though some parts of GameSpot's
original review still hold true tf2 has
changed over the years as has the
landscape of PC gaming the question that
this updated review seeks to answer is
how well is Team Fortress 2 holding up
in 2014 against the current crop of
competitors for your time and money the
short answer is it's holding up quite
well quite well indeed the core action
pits two teams of players against each
other in a battle to capture points move
a cart or steal a briefcase the
objective is always very straightforward
it's the interplay between the nine
playable classes that makes things much
more varied and interesting the speedy
scout the militant heavy the diligent
engineer the conniving medic the pesky
sniper the sneaky spy
the feisty pyro the explosive soldier
the even more explosive demo man all of
these dudes have straightforward tactics
advanced strategies and trixie
alternatives for you to learn how to
exploit and how to defend against
learning the ropes and getting the hang
of your chosen role is a gratifying
experience and there's a lot of subtlety
to each class that once mastered can
make you a much deadlier competitor but
the variety of classes should also tempt
you to mix things up and oftentimes you
need to be flexible with your choice of
character in order to avoid ending up on
a catastrophic ly imbalanced squad it is
team fortress after all and it has been
for wot the basics of the game haven't
really changed much over the years so if
you stopped playing it a few years ago
and come back for a few matches you'll
find things are very familiar there have
been some notable changes though as well
as regular infusions of new weapons and
items amidst the sea of stuff available
in the store some things can be unlocked
through play and some must be purchased
with actual money many offer nothing
more than a playful twist on the games
already cheeky cartoon aesthetic and
there's some mild appeal in donning a
spooky top hat or a golden Brock Samson
s mullet and taunting your phone in
addition to the cosmetic options there
are also a lot of weapons and items that
offer small buffs or subtle tweaks to
your attributes these generally give
experienced players some room for
strategic variation but they don't do a
whole lot to influence the core action
some weapons however give your character
a new chargeable and expendable power
and these are the ones that make things
interesting the Scout can build hype
which turns a usual double jump into a
triple quadruple and quintuple jump and
the soldier can build rage that allows
him to rally his nearby teammates to do
extra damage and then there are the
totally out there loadouts like the one
that turns the grenade launching Demoman
into an extra from the movie Braveheart
[Music]
these options help broaden the field of
viable strategies which helps keep
combat feeling lively and varied perhaps
the biggest divergence from the game's
origins comes in the co-operative mode
man versus machine in it you and a few
other human players must prevent hordes
of robotic incarnations of tf2 splices
from delivering a bomb to your base even
on the easiest level the robot legions
are fierce enough to test the mettle of
an unorganized team this is a mode where
carefully planned weapon choices and
defensive strategies can mean the
difference between succeeding and having
to try try again though it lacks the
frenetic unpredictability of competitive
play the cooperative mode can still
provide satisfaction for those dedicated
enough to see it through but competition
is the real draw and the Team Fortress 2
community can certainly be competitive
on some servers you might be berated for
unwitting breaches of etiquette while
others might welcome you with helpful
tips and uber charges the community for
tf2 is an intriguing one not just for
their deep knowledge of and passion for
the game but for their creative efforts
in designing new weapons items and maps
that have since become part of the
experience it feels like a community of
curators without whom the game may well
have dwindled away and passed into
obsolescence years ago
staying relevant even a year after
release is rare for a competitive
shooter and yet dear Team Fortress 2
still lively after seven years in the
business at times it feels like the same
game you could have played back then and
at others it feels like no one will ever
quite nail class-based shooter
competition the way tf2 does though your
free-to-play options may have increased
considerably in the past few years there
aren't many that do it as well as Team
Fortress 2
you
[Music]